depuis qu'existe l'organisation
terroriste état islamique ces
djihadistes ont recruté jusqu'à trente
mille combattants du monde entier grâce
à une puissante propagande en ligne ou
des chats sur et que venir s'installer
dans le califat autoproclamé
c'est à dire sur les territoires syriens
et irakiens pris par les djihadistes
était une obligation pour tout musulman
comme celle de prier jeûner et faire le
pèlerinage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
des milliers de citoyens russes ont
quitté leur pays pour rejoindre les
terroristes beaucoup d'entre eux ont
emmené femmes et enfants et beaucoup
sont morts l'est sont des enfants dans
des villes en ruines où des camps pour
enfants que fait-on papa papa est déjà
un shahid
mon père est un chef et son père est un
chahid et se passer mon père est en vie
je lui dirais de venir nous chercher
facilement et moi alors qu'en russie
les familles de ces enfants les
attendent et les recherches
as tu une grand mère j'ai une grand-mère
et un grand père aux habitudes en ce
moment dans cette ville aux abbés très
loin très très loin
majolie khalidya grâce à un reportage
télévisé filmé dans un refuge pour
enfants de bagdad
les grands-parents de ses fils les ont
reconnus depuis makhatchkala la ville où
elle vivait avec leurs parents il y a
quelques années ces mamies et papys ils
veulent te récupérer fatima et war vous
voulez y aller
maman veut y aller aussi
mais je ne dirai pas où aller je dirais
maman n'est pas morte
maman et à la rivière tout a commencé
avec le petit bilal après la chute de
mossoul
les soldats irakiens la sortie de sous
les ruines d'une maison
on l'a montré sur toutes les chaînes de
télé et sa mère l'a reconnu et bien sûr
j'ai immédiatement contacté nos services
spéciaux et le garçon est rentré chez
lui quelques jours plus tard match pour
que enfin bon
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'autres
mères qui avaient peur même d'en parler
en cachette ont commencé à venir nous
voir à nier staline
je suis fatigué de pleurer j'en ai assez
des larmes je pleure jour et nuit à qui
parler
le jour la nuit c'est la même chose pour
moi je pleure comme ça comment supporter
ça je vais avoir 60 ans en septembre
comment supporter ça je peux pas mon
fils unique est parti je n'ai plus de
fils il ne s'est pas demandé ce que je
ferais sans lui je ne parle pas de lui
mais des femmes et des enfants dernier
ramené les à la maison bien sûr je me
suis d'abord là dessus du mieux que j'ai
pu mais si j'avais su à ce moment là
quel point le problème était vaste
honnêtement je n'aurais jamais osé
intervenir
c'est vraiment très grave et très
douloureux je suis l'une de nos
organisations a dans sa base environ
2000 personnes au bon tri city ce sont
des mères et des enfants de la russie de
la chine et du caucase mais aussi des
pays européens
cette femme a passé presque trois ans
sur le territoire de l'état islamique
elle nous a demandé de ne pas montrer
son visage ni de révéler son identité
car même après être rentrée chez elle
elle reçoit toujours des menaces de
morts des partisans des terroristes dans
l'islam il ya un commandement divin
cuisine
s'il ya un endroit sur terre où la loi
de dieu règne c'est tous les croyants
devrait s'y trouvaient le jour du
jugement dernier à la dira où il ya un
endroit mais vous n'êtes pas allé là aux
rennais la loi divine
j'avais peur de péché parce que tous les
musulmans se rendent à cet endroit
lumineux est propre
alors que j'ai choisi une vie mondaine
et je reste là voilà pourquoi j'ai pris
mes enfants et j'y suis allé
[Musique]
seguy aujourd'hui des cheveux tellement
peur que même une mouche ne passera sans
passeport mais c'était différent à
l'époque à istanbul en turquie à la
frontière jetant tout le monde nous
voyait arriver et comprenez on allait
tout cela était parrainée par des ch
on nous disait tout sera payé il suffit
simplement de venir et tout le monde
était excité tout le monde partait pas
seulement les jeunes combattants des
familles entières avec des grands mères
et des grands pères ils vendaient leurs
maisons et déménagé en syrie beaucoup
d'entre nous se disait on pourra
toujours essayer si ça ne plaît pas on
reviendra mais ce n'a pas été aussi
facile
[Musique]
qui prend les enfants
en 2017 khadidja et fatima ont été
rendus à leurs grands parents qui ne les
avait pas vus depuis deux ans il ne
savait même pas si elle était encore en
vie je suis rentré à la maison à soirée
j'ai demandé ou et abdou rakhmane et on
m'a dit il est parti une semaine plus
tard il nous a envoyé un message sur wat
saab disant nous sommes en turquie je me
suis senti mal je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi il était parti cette campagne
battait son plein au daguestan certains
se sont rendus en syrie d'autres en irak
puis ils ont dit nous sommes à mossoul
[Musique]
il ya là beaucoup de nos frères du
daguestan bref vous y trouverez tout le
caucase et beaucoup de russes je me suis
rendu auprès d'une famille que je
connaissais du daguestan il avait trois
enfants et moi j'en avais 4 le mari de
cette femme a tout fait pour me trouver
un logement isolé il n'a pas réussi en
fin de compte et a dit je n'arrive pas
viens vivre avec nous on te donnera un
logement seulement si tu te maries donc
j'ai décidé de me marier pour sortir de
cette situation
mais mon mari est mort huit mois plus
tard
beaucoup se sont mariés comme ça épatant
puis ils sont devenu veuf parce que
leurs maris sont morts rapidement
on leur disait évidemment que ce serait
l'endroit le plus juste sur terre que ce
dieu et serait juge que la loi de dieu
régnerait il promettait une vie selon la
charia mais il monte et quand les gens
ont commencé à chuter qu'elle charrie ce
n'est pas dans la charia cette cruauté
ce n'est pas religieux de traiter les
gens comme ça et il nous répondait ce
sont les autres de dèche
c'est nous qui avons inventé ça pour
instaurer l'ordre
la plupart des hommes en prison là bas
ne voulait pas se battre
ils voulaient fuir mais personne ne leur
a donné cette chance
on ne les avait pas appelé pour les
laisser rentrer chez eux ensuite
je leur ai dit qu'ils seraient
bombardées qu'il fallait partir et ils
ont répondu qu'ils allaient le faire
mais qu'ils étaient dans le 3e groupe
ils ont collecté 5000 $ par personne
pour que les kurdes ouvre un couloir
apparemment c'est là qu'on les a
découverts sont dit que ça a été rapide
qu'ils n'ont pas souffert mais je n'y
crois pas les histoires de cani cha sont
horribles quand elle en parle jeudi
arrête oublie ça parfois elle commence à
décrire comment les enfants y mourrait
comment les adultes qui nous reste c'est
terrifiant
c'était une mauvaise car ce n'était pas
vraiment bien
ma mère voulait partir mais d'autres
personnes labatut les adultes et
prennent leurs enfants maman est
maintenant à la rivière elle est vivante
et us et ouais mon père tiens il y avait
qu à l'art
elle n'appelle jamais en pleurant maman
ou papa
qu'en fait il m'a dit maman maman
khadidja arriver dit maman est à la
rivière ne demande pas où elle est ne
pense pas à elle elles ont 5 ans et demi
et trois ans et demi
[Musique]
j'ai vécu ici avec mes parents je m'en
souviens c'était à ma mère ça c'est
laure ayez de notre famille papa dormait
dessus ce sont nos serviettes celle de
papa à celle de maman la mienne celle de
fatima regardez j'ai trouvé quelque
chose c'est quoi je sais pas faudrait
demander à mes parents mais je n'ai pas
de parents au sens ma mère et mon papa
maintenant mon père a moins il est avec
à la wii c'est vrai ce chien tous les
vêtements sont à leur place je n'ai
touché à rien tout est resté comme avant
pourquoi avez-vous tout laisser comme ça
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'elles sont
revenus là parce que je n'ai rien touché
c'est peut-être pour ça
j'ai essayé de m'enfuir tout seul mais
ça n'a pas marché
ensuite on m'a dit qu'une autre personne
voulait aussi s'échapper mais pour
partir nous avons dû nous marier car il
n'y avait pas d'autre moyen pour
communiquer pour parler nous sommes
entrés en contact avec un général kurde
et l'a dit qu'il allait vérifier nos cas
et que si nous avions participé à aucun
combat
il nous laisserait partir mais ils ne
l'ont pas fait ils nous ont trompé le
camp de réfugiés d'al hall est devenu
une prison pour plus de 70000 personnes
qui ont fui les zones de combats
la température y monte jusqu'à 60 degrés
cette chaleur tue et puis le froid
arrive vous vivez dans le désert et en
hiver ce je ne sais pas le froid est
juste irréel
il y as pénurie de nourriture d'eau et
de soins dans le camp selon les
organisations des droits de l'homme
plusieurs personnes meurent ici chaque
jour
[Musique]
la noce mangou ado je ne peux pas
décrire en une ou deux minutes à quel
point nous regrettons d'avoir commis une
aussi grave erreur dans nos vies en
décidant de partir pour la syrie soit
chez nous il nous ne sommes pas partis à
cause des bombardements ou de la fin
nous avons pris en toute conscience la
décision de partir parce que nous avons
renoncé à cet état nous ne voulons pas y
vivre ou en faire partie nous voulons
rentrer à la maison
si on me reste des enfants meurent ici
beaucoup sont morts de maladies simples
comme la diarrhée et on les amène à
l'hôpital et on en forme simplement un
tweak la mère que son enfant est décédé
termine samedi les enterrements match il
n'y a pas de cimetière
pire la première chose que nous vous
demandons c'est de nous pardonner et
plus nous vous demandons votre aide je
ne sais pas quoi faire je veux rentrer à
la maison je suis fatigué d'être ici ici
il ya des femmes très agressive qui met
plus aux tentes et battent les gens je
ne sais pas quoi faire s'il vous plaît
et des mois rentrer chez moi je trouve
indigne que les gens nous accuser nous
disent vous aider les terroristes à
loison chef de quoi cet enfant est il
coupable pourquoi blâmer ses enfants ce
sont les parents qui les ont fait venir
et ils ont fini par être victimes de la
guerre
vingt-et-une femme toute citoyenne russe
ont été condamnés à perpétuité en irak
elles sont en prison à bagdad avec leurs
enfants en l'absence de traité approprié
entre les deux pays
les femmes ne peuvent pas purger leur
peine en russie mais les autorités
irakiennes ont fait des concessions pour
les enfants ce qui a permis de commencer
à travailler pour les faire rentrer
je pose sur j'attends ma nièce ou mon
petit rayon de soleil nous je l'attends
stoch ma soeur aînée est parti avec ses
deux petites filles furent en elle et sa
fille jeannette font partie des
personnes condamnées à la prison à vie
elle a dit qu'elle allait vivre en
turquie et je lui ai demandé de me
montrer leurs films ont tous montré
qu'en coup mais comment savoir si c'est
une rue en turquie en irak
j'ai pris conscience qu'il n'était pas
en turquie parce que tous les jeunes qui
sont allés ils disaient qu'ils allaient
en turquie elle m'a dit oui
uniquement quand j'ai demandé
directement est ce que vous êtes là bas
[Musique]
je ne pense pas vraiment qu'elle
cherchait une meilleure vie parce
qu'elle avait des projets ici nous
construisions ensemble d'une maison sur
le terrain que nos frères nous avait
offert nous étions toujours proche nous
nous serrions les cool on était
tellement heureuse
tout est à l'abandon d'un conte en jeu
il y avait une clôture entre une nous
avions planté des fleurs des lilas ici
il y avait des raisins vous voyez ça a
été abandonnée c'est ce qu'il en reste
mais je n'ai plus la force de m'occuper
de tout cela toute la construction a
déjà été payé jusqu'au toit
s'il avait prévu de partir pourquoi
aurait-il payer
ce
je ne sais pas comment je vais vivre
sans eux ils ne se sont pas battus pour
que rien de tout ça une condamnation à
perpétuité
est-ce que cinq dix ou quinze ans
n'aurait pas suffi t'es dur au soft il
survivre même dix ans dans ces
conditions se ventile y survivre
za guide est s'est retournée à la maison
il y a deux ans elle est l'une des rares
femmes à ne pas avoir été capturés ou
jetés en prison en quittant les
territoires pris par les djihadistes
mon mari a décidé d'aller en turquie
il n'a rien dit sur la syrie juste pour
jeter un coup d'oeil et travailler un
peu tous ses amis allaient aussi il est
parti il a dit que c'était calme et là
bas qu'il n'y avait rien de ce qu'ont
montré à la télé qu'il n'y avait pas de
guerre quelque chose comme ça je la
suppliait de le quitter mais elle ne l'a
pas fait elle disait je suis dans
l'embarras
que diront les gens j'ai entendu par ci
par là qu'il lisait des prières qu'il
était très religieux se marient la
changer je ne suis pas contre l'islam ou
la religion
j'observe tout tout ce qui se passe ici
m'exaspère dans le showroom presse
croate
ils ont recruté des gens pour y aller
puis les ont tous tués taseer
[Musique]
je lui disais que je voulais partir que
je ne pouvais pas y vivre
chaque fois que je commençais à en
parler c'était un scandale en braille je
me disais tu veux mais tu laisseras les
enfants je ne te les rendrait pas
atteint mais à quoi bon vivre si mes
enfants sont à la guerre quelque part
nous connaissons de nombreuses histoires
où les maris sont soumis à une telle
pression
ils prennent les enfants ou divorcent
quand cav les femmes du caucase ne
peuvent pas refuser de rejoindre leur
mari bonjour il n'y a aucune issue pour
eux si cela les attrape
ils seront exécutés si ceux ci les
attrape ils seront mis en prison elle
avait besoin d'argent mais je ne pouvais
pas lui en envoyer car c'est aussi
illégal
qu'on sorte un mentor danny wood on ne
peut pas en sortir facilement girard qui
ont réussi ils ont fait secrètement
comme ça personne ne vous montrera le
chemin c'est chacun pour soi
je me fiche est de ce qui se passerait
si je rentrais simplement à la maison
l'essentiel pour moi était que mes
enfants ne soient pas capturé par les
kurdes ou maltraitées par quiconque
qu'ils soient ici à la maison en prenant
aussi en compte les camps nous n'avons
pas été à la maison depuis quatre ans
tout le monde est rentré à la maison
sauf nous il ne laissait pas nos proches
nos voir les services spéciaux du
daghestan nous ont rencontrés et nous
ont amenés presque avec des menottes qui
a trop fait rien je ne savais pas que
nous étions sur la liste des personnes
recherchées ici je n'en savais rien
comme les autres femmes revenus des
territoires contrôlés par des shs zag
dette a été reconnu coupable de
participation à un groupe armé illégal
est condamnée à huit ans dans une
colonie pénitentiaire
la peine a été prolongée à 13 ans
jusqu'à ce que son plus jeune enfant et
14 ans peu importe qui est votre mari ou
à quoi il ressemble vous devez lui obéir
c'est notre éducation
que peut-on dire de plus il a fallu près
d'un an à la russie à l'irak pour
négocier le retour des enfants des
condamnés à perpétuité à bagdad chez
leurs proches
non
ne commencez pas où nous allons tous
pleuré non tiens bon tiens bon
ça s'échappe
[Musique]
ne t'inquiète pas comme tu as grandi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
ça je n'ai pas reconnu il avait deux ans
la dernière fois quand je les ai vus tu
veux vivre avec moi tu vas vivre avec
moi avec maman mon petit avec ce moment
[Musique]
je suis la soeur de ta maman maman
arrive bientôt
mais jusqu'à ce qu'elle arrive tu vas
vivre avec moi d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
huit petits enfants
voice de belles filles et deux fils et
aucun d'entre eux n'est ti si près de
moi ils n'ont pas pensé à moi
comment je vivrai ici tout seul
[Musique]
je ne veux pas vivre dans une pièce vide
voici mon fils cadet mais voici les mais
hélas ce sont les enfants du cadet
est ce du fils aîné je veux qu'il
revienne
je ne souhaiterais pas une telle vie à
mon pire ennemi
s'il suicide n'était pas un péché je
serais morte depuis longtemps je suis en
larmes comme ça jour et nuit sur que je
pleure je me souviens 2 comment
répondront-ils de cela ils disent c'est
probablement le destin maman mais votre
destin dépend de vous vous répondrez
pour vos enfants des souffrances et des
abus qu'ils ont subis
vous répondrez de tout cela j'ai tout
essayé j'ai contacté tout le monde j'ai
toujours pensé qu'au moins l'un d'entre
eux pourrait revenir à mon nom depuis
trois ans maintenant je suis tout seul
blood
il y avait des gens là-bas quittés
heureux qu'ils aient des frappes
aériennes en jetant un frère musulman
m'a dit un jour pour des shows les
frappes aériennes sont la miséricorde
d'allah parce qu'on ne peut pas arrêter
ces gens ni leur sauvagerie qu'il nous
infligeait là bas
[Musique]
je connaissais un haut fonctionnaire de
l'état islamique sa femme était une de
mes connaissances et lui a demandé
l'état islamique est il un moyen
d'évacuer les femmes vers la turquie
vous pouvez faire sortir c'était à
l'époque où tout était un cercle et
comme l'irak et il a dit oui c'est
possible
alors pourquoi vous ne vais pas il n'a
pas répondu on tient en octobre 2019 le
gouvernement américain a annoncé que le
leader de dèche abou bakr al bagdadi
avait été tué au cours d'un raid
les autorités américaines affirment
qu'une expertise adn a confirmé
l'identité du terroriste
les restes d'al bagdadi ont été jetés
dans la mer
ou est ce monstre ou itil personne n'a
vu son corps rien bien sûr il a rempli
de sacs d'argent et il est parti
quelques parts et quelqu'un l'a aidé
mais ce n'est pas si simple ça ne s'est
pas produit d'un coup comme c'était
prévu
[Musique]
cela fait presqu'un an kamina a été
ramenée de la prison de bagdad
avec 30 autres enfants de femmes russes
purgeant des peines à perpétuité en irak
elle pense toujours à sa mère elle lui
manque toujours elles demandent des
nouvelles
on la voit sourire mais ses yeux sont
tristes beaucoup d'enfants qui sont
revenus sont toujours en contact les uns
avec les autres
ils s'écrivent je vois leurs photos ils
sont tous tristes ils sont inquiets ils
souffrent tous une fois je les vues en
sanglots yacoub de ce procès j'ai
demandé ce qui s'était passé elle a dit
qu'elle voulait retourner dans la
cellule de sa mère nous espérons
toujours qu'elles reviendront sur le
monde
quand j'entends des gens dire que le
travail est stoppée que ces femmes ne
vont jamais rentré honnêtement j'en ai
des sueurs froides
je sors et je me dis non qu'est ce que
je vais dire à ces mères c'est tellement
dur genre nous continuerons ce travail
nous continuerons à nous battre comme je
pense que je continuerai jusqu'à la fin
de mes jours
nous allons nous battre
depuis 2010 est l'organisation de
défense des droits de l'homme
objectif à aider à ramener plus de 200
femmes et enfants russes de syrie et
direct
bon moi je suis mouillé qu'est ce que je
t'ai dit et on on ne mange pas le sable
plus de 2500 femmes russes avec enfants
sont toujours dans les camps de réfugiés
des prisons ou en captivité chez des
terroristes
[Musique]